outer space this is cool we got a
diagram of space rockets but first bad
news as most of you know the SpaceX
first manned rocket launch was called
off well just push three days back
well it says called up but I'm building
suspense man give me no but that's
that's incorrect that's false
information oh it's true
it wasn't called off it is technically
the truth the best kind of the truth it
was called off to be postponed till
Saturday so it's gonna happen so many
extra words for nothing for fun it was a
storm all right but here's what I said
this early on imma say it again Elon
Musk I think in all likelihood it's fair
to say or at least from the way I view
of the world most important human being
on the planet you know what I am
inclined to agree with you cuz you're
right we we do need something to unite
us and we're not even I know that this
won't unite us are you sure I'm positive
we have seen a you know man
like I know it's cliche to hear Tim
Poole complain about the left be honest
but they're complaining that he's
wasting money on other planets out of
our own and people are saying things
like could you imagine if Elon Musk was
spending money on health care instead of
rockets and I'm like do you know that
like a lot of advancements in technology
were developed through space funding
like technolog technologies and more
importantly do you know that the money
that Elon Musk spends stays on earth
yeah they don't get that and he's
spending it in America too right you
spend it here it hires people it pays
for equipment and they build a rocket
and then the rocket goes to another
planet he's bringing space launching
back to America that's huge we had to
pay Russia so much money to use their
rocket to put one American into space I
don't actually have the numbers but
that's the truth we've been we needed
Russia we needed their rocket because
they have the Soyuz that they've been
bringing us into into space now we can
do it on our own that only cost me like
1.5 million dollars to go up into space
done that's incredibly cheap reusable
rocket sane now we're not paying Russia
why are we talking about that that's
that's huge yeah when he fired when he
when he launched the Tesla into outer
space yeah everyone's complaining there
was it was a
all these it's easy scarrans bro you
know it's the it's the it's it's caring
culture ah something I can complain
about yep we should be spending that
money on health care for people not
putting a car in outer space
I love the Karen it's like it was a test
flight it was a payload they needed to
put something in there that weighed a
certain amount exactly it was pretty
cool
any he runs Tesla so we put a guy the
astronauts to dummy in it and the other
thing too is like it's inspirational you
know it's like how many little kids saw
that that you know hot rod red
convertible in outer space we yeah spit
on it and they were like I want to I
want to be that astronaut yeah yeah the
video of Yellin was crying when he found
out like Buzz Aldrin or whatever
criticized him no what does it say I
don't know exactly what happened but let
me let me see if I can google it real
quick
it's terrible yeah you um cried he cries
a lot a little emotional it was it was
he was here we go Elon Musk almost Neil
Armstrong here we go Oh what is this I
don't know exactly what happened I'm
appearing teary-eyed over Neil Armstrong
reaction what was he reaction to
reacting to what was that all about
I thought it was Buzz Aldrin let's click
cried and see what happens
Elin musk almost in tears anyway look
whatever man let's bring it back to the
actual story yeah but uh he was being
criticized because like something I
don't know like some kid playing with
toys or whatever and it was like for him
it was devastating because he was
probably it was probably a hero's death
right Aldrin like being tall like a one
of the greatest you know no no that was
Buzz I think was like Neil I'm sure
whatever another one it's the same thing
same edge line of space man it's like
man you went to the moon like wow you
know he probably looked up to him
forever
so now to hear him criticize him his
product that was probably devastating
forget it I think he lands cried before
- he's an eccentric dude he's a little I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that well in principle and then when
Elon Musk tweets some crazy yeah crazy
nonsense and people are like their
stocks are crashing the company's
freaking out and then it's like he's
being accused of like shorting the
market and all the other crazy stuff
it's like you know
there whatever whatever I'm not gonna
say he's exactly like Trump but they
have a lot in common there's there's
some weird overlap between the eccentric
billionaire personality types you know
maybe something about being eccentric
makes you more likely to be a
billionaire maybe you know ya know ya
risks but let's talk about why we got go
to Mars man yes because of this it's
because a tiny asteroid is super close
to earth flyby shows planetary
protection in action this asteroid yeah
I don't know how many people know about
this this asteroid if it hit us you know
what have happened it would have burned
up in the atmosphere and we would never
have noticed that's that is true yes now
hold on hold on no I'm working I'm
working it up to it okay you you do it
then like I'm just glad we're talking
about this actually actually to be fair
he weighed this story huge asteroid 1998
Oh artoo will zip harmlessly by earth
April 29th through the telescope this
one even bigger yeah that was it that
was much bigger yeah and you know what
have happened if this one hit us well
how big was this one do they say was
that the four kilometer one no no no
that's that's Chicxulub actually the
biggest one one point one miles okay
that's that's Chicxulub size 1 to point
2 point 5 miles so if that asteroid hit
us we would all be dead the little one
was the joke yeah but when they saw it
when they show that little asteroid
they're like hey look you know our
planetary defense works or whatever it's
like it alerted us that was coming
mm-hmm this thing starts coming this
thing hits us we don't exist anymore
that's correct we're done we would be
done yeah well there would be there'll
be mold people like you know the people
who live under Las Vegas and New York
yes those people yeah I don't even know
about that more like I don't know yeah I
don't know if that would work because it
was like that that asteroid turned the
sky to molten lava essentially the sky
yes because what happened was when it
hit he kicked up so much dust in the
atmosphere that covered the entire
planet so when it was reentering the
planet it would it was clumping together
and then burning so the whole sky was
fire yeah but you're underground right
it lasted for a long time well it wasn't
just like and over listen listen there
are people who live under New York City
mm-hmm big complex maze yeah
and there are rats yeah so now right now
they go up for food right but let's say
this massive thing hits Australia right
okay and then it wraps around the planet
and then eventually reaches New York you
know we go a couple thousand years of
the subterranean you know mole people
they eat the rats the rats breed from
eating you know funguses and you got
mole people that live underground and
are pale with big eyes and they eat rats
okay huh yeah that's that's humanity's
fate okay is that better than less we
get to Mars and get to the moon and we
start setting up going into space
comfortably that we can get out and
handle something like the Chuck slub
meteorite and we you but you know to be
to be fair though as much as I can
praise Elon Musk for trying to do this I
think one of the problems is our method
of transportation strapping someone to
the in the tip of a giant metallic tube
and putting a bunch of explosives in it
and firing the explodes at the back to
launch him into space you know we got to
figure out I don't know man some kind of
anti-gravity what was the you were
telling me about the virgin virgin plane
oh they tried doing orbit through a
virgin orbit seventh 747 or something it
was like a tap so top then once they get
as high as they can they launch it and
it didn't work because Elon Musk
commented on and he said orbit is hard
you know it took us four tries that was
their first attempt but that could be
big it could really lower the cost if
virgin can figure out how to get into
orbit from just flying up yeah yeah only
cheaper than yeah but it's not it's not
even about that cuz like the Jets it's
you know to be honest I understand that
the achievement humans have made with
like creating the jet turbine engine
these massive you know rolls-royce
things whatever yeah can make a multi
like where's a 200-ton object fly it's
impressive
yeah it is but all we're really doing is
like swimming oh you need to manipulate
some natural forces okay maybe it maybe
it maybe it's a sci-fi pipe dream it's
like basically it's learning how to
manipulate gravity that would be the
thing we need to figure out because
that's we're spending so much energy to
get off the planet to escape gravity
right
and then think about how long it takes
to even get to Mars and his men seven
seven months and it's inhospitable so
what are we doing somebody mentioned
like firing a hundred fifty thousand
nukes at the IceCaps Tutera fortress to
begin the tear formation process huh and
then it would still take you know
decades to centuries and it would also
radiate all of that water well their
nukes are intentionally radioactive so
they could theoretically create bombs
that don't create okay so yeah I believe
there are some very very very powerful
nuclear bombs that have no radioactive I
didn't know that what Brent today I
learned interesting well I'm not
completely sure I'm not an expert on
nuclear weapons I just did a segment one
time for Discovery Channel so it's like
we looked at on all these different
weapons and their radiuses rate rate out
radii yeah yeah and what we learned is
that many of them are intentionally
radioactive so that you have physical
destruction of resource followed by
organic destruction of human being
that's a mess yeah but anyway yeah we're
gonna get inside track no no MIT may
look at that no no I think this is an
important conversation maybe maybe we do
irradiate Mars and then for what couple
decades we're not gonna be there we're
terraforming the planet
maybe I mean is it too cold though is
the gravity too weak is there an
atmosphere those are the problems there
is a very thin atmosphere in it
sustainable real atmosphere there the
thing is here's what no one's thinking
about Earth has a magnetic field Mars
lost that magnetic field a long time ago
if Mars used to look like Earth they had
running water we know this so the mek
beat the magnetic field being gone
it's bombarded by all sorts of stuff
from space that not the atmosphere or
not it doesn't have a magnetic field so
solar flares are gonna hit Mars and just
bombard it solar flares come at us our
magnetic field pushes it around us and
we don't feel that we don't we don't
feel that at all so it's what we can see
the Aurora's that's cool right that's
the result well Mars doesn't have
Aurora's anymore right because it just
gets hit and then why go to Mars
I mean we can have a base there we can
yeah you know like BIOS biodomes yeah I
guess you know it makes more sense to me
to go to the moon you know and maybe
figure out a way to keep the moon at the
same place so it doesn't it doesn't move
away anymore well if we if we mine it
and strip matter from it with that I
think it would fly away a little
actually that's a good point because if
it was a little bit lighter would
Earth's gravity be able to maintain it
better I don't know I mean I bet it
would have to be a significant amount of
material how long until the moon to make
it this way from like a million year 100
million years that long before then if
we don't sure that's true but at the
same time it is moving away and we don't
know the effect I mean it affects our
planet you know when it was in the time
of the dinosaurs it was like four
thousand miles away from Earth its
massive it was massive it was crazy math
imagine imagine the water behold as it
spun around there how far away is it now
I don't know the exact exact because to
understand the difference yeah of like
why four thousand is significant you
gotta know where it is now it is two
hundred thirty thousand nine hundred
miles away yeah do you imagine looking
up and just seeing like it's like it's
like that Zelda game yeah I was mask at
night at night it was as bright as day
on the planet Earth so well if it was a
full moon anyway that was when the moon
first got formed you're saying or when
when the dinosaurs were roaming the
earth i I don't know this is it was born
significantly longer before that you
know so but when they were roaming it
was huge so when was that three hundred
million years ago or something that
makes sense I don't know when actually I
have the Chicxulub I think we got a
factor this cuz cuz they got it how far
away is the moon moving from Earth every
year like an inch and a half so what's a
million inches I don't know how many
miles is a million inches miles oh my
gosh so divide it by twelve and then I'm
trying to find without the wind chicks
how that math adds up oh yeah that's
fine I don't know if that's so saying I
don't know the exact math
don't think I'm just kind of I don't
think it was riffing off miles when I
was I gotta meet him find out yeah oh
right I didn't know that that's really
interesting see we that'd be cool though
like the tide it was like an
interstellar you know where the tide was
a gigantic like 300 foot wall coming in
that would not be maybe that would be
fun I'm sure surfers would be like yes
yeah but they were standing in like two
feet of water so like you'd ride to the
top and fall to your death that's a good
point
and you're and you're on this planet and
it's like 7:00 every hour they're seven
years on earth were you able to find it
okay so so it was 4,000 miles closer
yeah yeah that makes right now it's two
to 240,000 miles away yeah so it was
bigger though for sure
bigger in the sky yeah yeah it was two
percent bigger two percent really that's
it no this I don't know what this is
actually this is just a random answer
I'm finding but wait but it would have a
noticeable effect on everything else so
I mean yeah what happens when the moon
finally just breaks away and leaves the
tide stop yeah I mean that's that's a
big part of our planet is the tie its
ship you think about it shifts the whole
ocean yeah the ones are around yeah what
stays wherever the moon is that's where
the tides are that's crazy and that
moves our entire planet of water and us
we're made of water
you know we've taught that it's like
worse like 75% water or something human
being yeah um like that let's let's
let's do we're all lunatics the real the
real problem is everything we're doing
now is cute okay yeah we both the
biodome on Mars but is it really gonna
be a sustainable functioning habitat
where humans grow and flourish and if
the earth gets blown up for whatever
reason are the Martians gonna be able to
do anything or are they gonna be
dependent upon earth but we really got
to talk about is we need faster travel
we need better propulsion better energy
efficiency truth and we need to
terraform a planet and get a magnetic
field going I don't know if we can do
that you know what do we do do like
drill designer of marzin
the core like in that movie remember the
movie that the core that's it was called
core core like the Earth's core was
stopping so they launched a bunch of
nukes to make it spin again well there's
no guarantee that would work that's a
movie no no we need liquid it needs
liquid iron and I don't know if what's
in the middle of Mars but I know earth
has liquid iron and our core and that's
why we have a metal forcefield
you know to keep out all those nasty
particles and radiation whatnot yeah we
need that so then it's it's it's right
now if we're talking about launching
rockets in a space to colonize things it
does seem like a waste of time mmm-hmm
maybe we need to start working on those
you know those tick tack UFO ships
everybody keeps talking about maybe we
need to build that yeah unless unless we
could also figure out better cryogenics
suspended animation I'm trying to find
work so then what we do is we in or so
oh there's so much crazy stuff we got to
talk about man check it out if we put
people if we built a big Space Station
and a Mars man and a moon base okay and
then used those to create a massive
vessel in space because it would be it
would be very very difficult to get a
very large vehicle off of the earth
right right you build it in space right
you put people in suspended animation
and then you kick them off to Alpha
Centauri or some you know who knows
where you calculate everything and you
cross your fingers and nothing knocks
you off course in a mite and then you're
heading in suspended animation for a
thousand years to make it to this new
planet where humans will land in a ship
and you're with like several hundred
people and that's it that's life and in
those thousand years while you're all
frozen a new vessel developed on earth
whizzes right past you and they point in
there like look Wow and then they beat
you there and then finally you wake up
as new planet there's just their cities
and it's same exact problems warming and
like populations Bufoni
and you're like you should have just
waited that sounds like a really good
book premise that you just gave to
whoever out there is out there like I
needed a new idea that's pretty good
though it's like it's one of the
perceived problems with space travel
that right now we're doing all these
things where we're like we're gonna rock
it to Mars but in 50 years we might have
developed antigrav maybe in 100 years
who knows yeah and so then all the work
being done to go these long distances is
just completely made obsolete yeah by
better technology or we just figure out
how to step into the fourth dimension
like walk over and enter back in in a
different spot you don't know that makes
more sense
yeah warping space-time you know and it
seemed it might seem impossible to us
now but we've done such amazing feats
with you know manipulating reality
already so imagining like what is it
Voyager is the satellite that like
exited the solar system yeah sure wanted
to I'm imagining we're like you know
we're all going like wow it finally left
and then in a hundred years you can like
drive up to it and feel like there it is
Voyager and there's like a security
detail yeah and it's like you wake up it
you know you go back to earth because
you can travel a ridiculous speeds and
you you wake up it's like a ten minute
commute you're like I do security for
the Voyager as it travels you know yeah
it's like a ten minute drive and then I
just basically get stationed me you next
to it because you don't want anyone
messing with it of course yeah you know
and that's your job and people like
people are coming and taking pictures
like could you imagine so the other
thing is time dilation right the faster
you go the slower time so we'll people
on Mars because there's lot to consider
here Mars is less dense there's less
gravity so that with a much smaller
would that mean they would experience
time going faster than we would are
slower if it's smaller yeah I don't know
the earth the the moon the Mars day is
different than the Earth Day there's
nothing to do with no I'm talking about
so time dilation is like if the faster
you go the slower time goes right so we
need to consider a couple things the
speed of the planet Mars compared to the
speed of the planet Earth that's what I
was just referencing I'm not talking
about days though mm-hmm I'm talking
about the actual kilometers per hour the
planet is actually moving okay so they
did this experiment Civics I think they
did this they took two two stopwatches
and they put one in like a mock jet and
one on a table and they had it zoom
around as fast as it could when it came
back and they had different times when
it landed huh yeah pretty cool I could
be wrong about that I this is not new
this is me reading fun stuff on the
internet mind you in fact check me but
the general like I want to know about
that sounds cool the faster you go time
slows down from your perspective that is
true though actually I was watching the
Scott Kelly documentary because he went
up and spent it wasn't a full year was
like three
in 48 days or something in space and he
has a twin and they came out and he's
like haha I'm a little bit I'm a little
younger than my medicine now so think
about this way can you can you look up
the speed earth is traveling around the
Sun and the speed Mars is travel around
the Sun okay because and while you're
doing that the general idea is if you
live on Mars and Mars is traveling less
than the speed of Earth okay then you
would be moving slower and experience
time faster than the people on earth
would unless Earth is traveling faster
so if like Earth is going at a hundred
thousand kilometers an hour and Mars is
going 75 then you're traveling different
speeds you will experience time
differently they get old on you you
would perceive time the exact same but
you'd like look to earth and people be
going like moving around all fast you
know and you'd be like so weird
so then think about unfortunately why
Star Trek is impossible this really
bummed me out when I when I when I read
about this when they travel fast in the
speed of light argue arguably you could
say they could get to you know alpha
colony you know you know whatever and
it's like a federation outpost and
everyone there is like you're supposed
to be here in two weeks and you're like
I'll be there in two weeks then you get
there and you you're you're in that your
warp 9 and you get there in two weeks
and it's like it's been two weeks and
now you're here that would just not be
how things happen right because earth is
traveling away different speeds from
whatever that Starbase is it could
literally be like the Starbase is moving
zero and the earth is moving so like
you're in different spaces and the whole
thing about Star Trek those when they
when they went to warp
there was a warp field around their ship
right that prevented time dilation but
what I mean is right all right yes okay
I thought so but what I'm saying is if
Mars is traveling at you know X
kilometers an hour and Earth is
traveling Y then the people living there
would both experienced time at different
rates to each other so then like if you
were traveling from Earth to Mars they
would perceive it as taking longer or
shorter or whatever until you met up
with them and then synchronized with
their you know speed so I'm gonna I
wanna I'm gonna bring it back to the
reason why we need to get back into
space and where's this article that
shows the the path so there was this are
you know that the
tiny one right no yeah yeah here it is
so I want I want you guys to see how
close the best we have right this one
here
no no scroll down okay so this is if you
can see right here this is the little
one that that came and this is earth so
it came within 4,000 miles of Earth that
that is incredibly close now it was only
like I was 20 feet wide or something so
you're right it would have burned up in
our atmosphere but they only they found
it hours ahead so what I'm saying is we
need to be able to handle this kind of
thing if it is the next Chicxulub that's
gonna hit us and just back in 1998 there
was that one that was four miles Y or
that it could have been four miles they
don't know exactly the the size of it
then maybe what we should be doing right
now
first and foremost before Mars maybe
ulong's wrong moon base you know then we
need gigantic space biodome and we can
have maybe we don't get Crona genex
right maybe you literally just have
generations of families who live on a
spaceship I think that's gonna happen
the problem with that is generations
forget and you will have by the third or
fourth generation people have never
experienced or know nothing about it
probably but if the if they old filters
you've seen it right that's right yeah
yeah and that's cool it's cool people
that just grew up in the belt and my
guys they got really long really tall
yeah they don't have gravity and then
you go to her degree and they're just
like oh I can't move right yeah the I
was reading about how we could do
artificial gravity right now with just
like you know like a spinning ship like
we often see right it doesn't work it
does technically but the reason I was
reading is that it creates an angular
force which makes you feel you can get
used to it uh-huh but you can feel a
pole in a direction due to the rotation
it's not a downward force it's an
angular force okay okay so it's spinning
so you it makes people feel sick you
might get used to it if you're born into
it and then you'd land on earth and
you'd be like oh yeah but not even that
like your whole perception will be
thrown out but then maybe that's it
maybe maybe we load up people on this
massive biodome vessel and then twelve
generations later they finally make it
to that planet well we got the Kobe
she Maru space tracking system yes this
is the spaceport space force receives
its Kobayashi Maru space tracking system
so this is something they're actually
working on at the space force is
essentially tracking all interstellar
objects that could potentially destroy
us Kobayashi Maru it's kind of like on
earth a Star Trek right well which is
kind of weird because the Kobayashi Maru
was unbeatable right so I know it was
this to see what captains would do in an
unwinnable situation so it's kind of I
don't know it's a little silly cuz it
doesn't exactly fit the lower but it's
it's still good to know that they they
have this stuff that they're actually
this is I think one of the most
important things we got to do is if if
they're it like you know that the movie
what is the movie with the thing come in
to hit us which one the asteroid coming
at us
was it pocalypse no there's there's deep
impact deep impact on an arm again arm
again yeah same movies basically so it's
the same movies but that's actually
really a potential like we need to be
able to handle that if it comes because
it's a possibility like things fly by
our planet all the time do you remember
when I was talking with Joe about I'm
like a the ark project leaving Venus and
then coming to Earth and terraforming it
mm-hmm and I think there's actually even
a simpler way of explaining what the
story could be what if we were the
children of the arc project that wasn't
a collapsing or dying planet okay it's a
planet you know a thousand light years
away that was like we're gonna load
y'all up on a ship
have at it and what if the aliens a
different solar system completely what
if the aliens we see are actually just
people and so it's like imagine this way
you you've seen Battlestar Galactica
yeah
they actually end up on earth in the end
spoiler so I mean at this point if you
haven't seen it this is not as
twenty-year-old twenty twenty years now
amazing show I thought it was it was
actually earth or just an earth-like
planet that they found out it was earth
ancient earth I thought it was maybe
whatever the point I don't know it
relates to the idea anyway right anybody
know you go ahead you knows no it's a
very advanced civilization of humans
okay
inhabit multiple planets and then or
maybe even they don't let's say there's
a planet somewhere far far away and
people asked the questions about why it
is our solar system is so perfect for us
like notably how Jupiter keeps the
asteroids away from crashing into the
inner planets that does a really good
job of that it's like a powerful filter
mm-hmm and Pete some people think it's
divine that it's you know it's the work
of the Lord
okay some people think it's just
probabilistic like of course we're here
we have a shield you know many many
shields right not just Jupiter and many
situations and what if it's an advanced
race on a on a planet that was under
constant bombardment but humans tell of
it you know developed and they said what
if we could find a planet that was
perfect they did is it that solar system
is excellent for a colony yeah and they
and that and let's say they take
technology slightly better than ours so
they created a massive vessel they
called it the Ark loaded everybody up
mm-hmm
carry on and they launched him out and
then when that ship finally got here
those people had no idea what life used
to be like for the past civilization
right cuz it's been a thousand years of
flying through space living in space
whatever you know so they come here and
they have this just like the ship can't
land on earth because it doesn't have
the ability to leave the planet it was
made in space it stays in space or maybe
the ship was named Atlantis and then
finally landed and then that was like
where it everything came from and then
finally after your you know millions of
years it just crumbled 100,000 a couple
hundred thousand wiped out millions
right right but now like you know like
like Joe was saying about bob lazar not
stuff us finding his ancient tech that's
why I brought it up I'm like what if
it's ours what if this ship just dropped
us off and they and they knew the ships
coming around and they are alike unit
1775 there's you know 3,000 of you this
will be your home we'll never see you
again and then they drop them off and
then the ship keeps going because like
think about what we would do what if we
made a big ship with thousands of people
on it mmm-hmm would we just stop at one
planet or would it make several stops
dropping a thousand people on each
planet that is deemed habitable TVs
receiving the universe yeah so that
humans never go extinct what if we are
the attempt not to go extinct that'd be
crazy
how much fun is that thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you